- And we're live!
Welcome everybody to
another YouTube hangout.
Super excited to be here with
good friend and one of my
favorite CEOs of all
time, Mr. Steven Kelly.
How are you doing?
- I'm fantastic, Evan.
I'm so excited to be in your home city.
This is Toronto and this place rocks.
- We're back together again live.
It's always great to be
able to do it face-to-face
and not just over the internet.
- Yeah, this is the second visit, no,
third one we've done live, I think,
when we've done Sage Summits.
- We did, CN Tower was the first one.
- Yes, CN Tower, wow.
- New Orleans, I don't think we did one.
- No, we did Chicago.
- We did Chicago and then
this is Toronto, third one.
So there we go.
Sage Summit's happening
here in Toronto today.
I was a mentor, speaker, tons of fun.
But we're spending an
hour with you guys today
to talk about how to turn your
business ideas into reality.
And we have to start it off
with Steven Kelly quotes
because that's what you
guys look forward to.
- So I've got three
quotes to kick it off with
and good ones, actually.
And I think also we might
have a few quotes from
some of the speakers who
we've had at Sage Summit
during the current broadcast.
So, first quote is every
morning you have two choices.
You continue to sleep with
your dreams or wake up
and chase them and make them happen.
- Nice!
- Then the second one, a great
author called Victor Hugo,
there is one thing stronger
than all the armies in the world
and that's an idea who has come to time.
The idea that time has come.
And the final one really,
actually we had him as a speaker,
I think it was in Chicago, Colin Powell.
- Yeah, last year.
- Amazing.
- Yep.
- He said, and he's so right,
a dream doesn't turn into
reality through magic.
It takes sweat,
determination, and hard work.
So you've got to make it happen.
And that's so important for entrepreneurs.
God, we all know, I think,
Evan and I would say
there's probably even periods in our life
where we just thought about stuff too much
rather than have that buzz for action
and just get on and do it sometimes.
We know it's right, especially
if you trust your instincts
is a good rule of life.
So, three great quotes to kick off with.
And, Evan, we're in your hometown
so let's get the show going.
- I like it.
And Steven's rocking some Canadian pride.
We've got the Canada pin happening.
Oh, there's Sage at the
top, too, I didn't see that!
Little Sage logo at the top.
The cuff links, you can't see his shoes.
He's got the shoes, he's
got the tattoo happening
on the arm.
- We keep going, okay, here we are,
upside down, sorry guys.
- There it is, look at that.
There it is, Canada flag.
- There it is, can you see it?
Canada flag.
I can't get my arm around.
Here we go there.
Pretty crazy.
- I love it, I love it.
Well, guys, I see already
questions pouring in so
come in, say hi.
I'm looking off to the
side to get your questions.
But before kind of diving
in on that, oh, update.
You know, since our last
hangout, the channel,
my channel just crossed 100 million views.
- Wow!
- Across the channel,
so, you've contributed
a good chunk of those.
- I love it.
On behalf of everybody out
there and there's some kind of
regular sort of viewers to
the channel and some new folks
to it, but I just want
to thank this guy, Evan,
for giving a lot of people
belief and conviction
and confidence to do
what they know is right
and pursue their dreams
and just make their dreams come true.
And this guy's been a
great role model, I know,
from just listening to a lot
of what you say about Evan.
And he's kind of changed lives
and given you the confidence
and the belief to actually
just start your business,
grow your business, and be successful.
So, credit to you.
So, and I know, actually I
know Evan as a good friend
and it's not about building
his brand or there's no ego
about this, he's just so
committed to your success
and just seeing you be the
entrepreneur that you can be.
- Thanks, man.
I got to bring this
guy with me everywhere.
That's a good intro.
I love it, I appreciate that.
Yeah, it's been fun.
I didn't, I wasn't even
tracking the number
and then someone on my team said, hey,
we just crossed 100 million views.
- Wow!
- Like, wow, that's great.
But, we're here to add value to you guys,
talk about how to turn your
business ideas into reality.
Before diving in on the questions,
which we're going to
get to, quick thoughts,
what's your overall bit of
advice on how to turn ideas
into reality for entrepreneurs?
- Yeah, I think actually an
amazing, not related to this,
but an amazing guy,
Martin Luther King said,
to climb that giant staircase,
you got to just take the first step.
And I think the golden rule
is if you have conviction,
you have belief, you have
an idea, then it's all about
down to you to make it happen.
And it is so easy to just worry
about stuff or think about
the reasons why you can't do it.
And I think for entrepreneurs,
that's leap, you know,
we all periods of
self-doubt, let's be honest.
But you've to have, you got
to clear those cobwebs away
and say, alright, I'm going to do it
and I'm going to absolutely do it.
And within Sage, I say to
all my colleagues, I say,
guys let's just do it.
If it's right for the customer,
walk in the shoes of the customer.
I keep an empty chair in every
meeting for the customer.
If it's the right thing to
do, then just go for it.
I'll give you 100% air cover.
And I far prefer you
fail fast, fail quick,
and then find the idea that
really meets the customer needs.
Then just think about
it in that kind of old
analysis paralysis, which kills companies,
kills entrepreneurs.
- I love it.
So guys, leave your
questions in the Comments.
Let's get to a few.
They're already pouring in.
Jerais' first question,
Jerais is a long-time viewer.
Is there a set process
that reliably, consistently
works for everyone on turning
a business idea into reality?
- Yeah, I think there's some golden rules.
I wouldn't say there's
a cookie cutter process
but there's some golden rules.
Kind of rule number one is
always live in the shoes
of your customer whether
it's a product or service.
And that rule never goes
away as you grow and scale
your business, actually.
You live in the shoes of your customer,
you know, really be where your audience is
and that's the start of everything.
Now, I, we've talked
about, and I love this,
if you've got something you
really get frustrated by
with a service that you're
receiving or a company
you deal with, think about how
do you disintermediate that
or do that a lot better than they can do
and then make that happen.
And a lot of businesses have
been created just through
the genius of people who
have become very frustrated.
So, I think the key thing
is golden rule number one
is just be where your customers
are and then have that
sort of biased reaction
to think of your idea
and then test drive it with,
hopefully, early adopter customers
to make sure it's real.
If it's real, let's get it up.
- Yeah, I would add, I think
you've got to make sure
you take an action.
I think a lot of entrepreneurs
have ideas but we're talking
in this episode how to
turn it into reality.
It's taking consistent action,
it's waking up everyday
and doing something to
move your business forward
even if you feel like it's too big an idea
or it's too scary.
I think a lot of times
people are so worried about
taking the perfect first step
that they don't do anything,
where there is no perfect first step,
it's just go out and do.
And like Steven started a vlog
on our last episode, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like 20 days ago he started
a vlog and you've done
a second episode.
- Yep.
- And you're doing a third one here?
- And, it's just, we're
going to get started
and we're going to learn each time.
And you're like, hey, give us
feedback and then we're going to
do it again and do it
again and do it again
and every time you do it, it gets better.
You know, there's no
perfect way to start a vlog,
you just get a camera out
and you start vlogging
and you make improvements every time.
And so I think a lot of times
entrepreneurs are in their
own way, in their own head
too much worrying about
how do I get started,
what first step do I take?
Just do something and
then tomorrow do it again,
and do it again, and every time
you get a little bit better.
That consistency is going
to be really important.
- Yeah, and I think, I
know a lot of entrepreneurs
and I'll say, and sometimes
I'd say this about me,
one of the things I'll
be critical of myself,
is sometimes, you know,
I do seek perfection.
Reality is, you know, we'll
probably never find perfection
on this planet.
And if you're looking to
have the perfect product
or the perfect sort of
market research or trialing
or whatever, you're just
never going to do that
and you're going to spin
yourself in circles.
You're much better off doing
exactly what Evan said,
is just that action, that
action orientation to start.
And, you know, on that video,
vlog, that we're doing,
honestly, I didn't know if it
met the need but I thought,
kind of a good idea so
why don't we just try it.
If it didn't work, we
didn't get the reaction,
we didn't the audience
who really said that we're
meeting the need that they have,
then we would have stopped it.
And I think the other thing,
actually, it's hockey,
we're in, this is a hockey
city, right, so Maple Leafs
over at the center, yeah?
And also, big plug for
his team, Blue Jays,
another great sport.
So, Toronto, great city, great culture,
great symphony orchestras, great theater,
but great sport too.
And Wayne Gretzky, arguably
one of the greatest
hockey players ever, amazing player.
You kind of watch some of
his dribbles on YouTube,
just out of this world.
What he said is he never, never, kind of,
he never runs to where the puck is,
he always runs to where it's going to be.
And I think we get inspired by
entrepreneurs who have ideas
about inventing the future, inventing,
taking customers on a journey
where the customer might not
even know they have a need, a latent need,
and just trying, and things
like smartphones have done this.
Clearly, 15 years ago, we
would have said it's probably
crazy to have a phone and
integrated computer device
with a calendar, and apps and stuff.
We probably wouldn't have
saw the logic of that
because we all kind of
walked around at that time,
either we're Blackberries,
another great, actually,
Canadian company, that
got disintermediated.
A great kind of lesson in
terms of missing a big shift
in that movement where they
didn't realize where the puck
was going to be.
They were putting the puck
on the ice and just keep on
going back to that puck
and you can't do that.
So, I think that bias for
action is so important
and, Evan, you're absolutely
spot on with that advice.
- Cool, alright.
Well, let's get some more questions.
I see them flowing in so
I'm going to scroll down
and see what we've got.
It's nice to have anything
at the Golden Forest.
Fifteen year old entrepreneur
who works remotely.
Sorry, I just got sent an
invitation from a good friend.
He's a 15 year old
entrepreneur who works remotely
on a daily basis.
Here to learn, do you have advice.
Do we have advice for a
15 year old entrepreneur
who wants to work remotely
in their business?
What advice would you give?
- Yeah, I think if you want to
work remotely then, I guess,
first of all you want to ask yourself
what are you passionate about?
You know, I know this guy on
my left is passionate about
helping entrepreneurs.
So, you know, the channel was
just a vehicle where he can
serve you, be your mentor,
give you great advice,
support your greater business.
So, the first thing is,
you know, as a 15 year old
there's got to be something you love.
You know, is it sport,
is it salsa dancing,
what is it you love that
really you get excited about?
Because if you get excited
about it you can inspire,
you know, a movement, a
movement of customers.
Then, the second thing, I think,
if you want to work remotely,
you got to think about
how are you going to deliver that service
or product to customers.
And again, I think the
world of social media
really does amplify that.
The Internet's changed everything.
And it's fantastic, it gives
people huge flexibility
in terms of where they work.
And as a matter, you know,
we're doing this broadcast
from Toronto, no fancy
studios, just a laptop.
Pretty low cost, probably the tech here
costs less than $1,000.
So the world has changed.
This would have been
unimaginable 10 years ago.
So, I'd say, yeah, absolutely
be passionate about
something you really love
because that will give you
your idea for the business.
And then think about where the customer is
and how you get there.
And I'd commend you if
you want to work remotely
to really look at social
media and the channels,
whether it's Instagram,
Facebook, or whatever channel,
where your audience is.
- Yeah, I would say also
continue to learn and reach out
and model success.
I wish that this existed when I was 15.
I wish I could have asked
Steven Kelly a question
as a 15 year old entrepreneur
and so I think continue to
surround yourself with
resources, with people,
you know, watch YouTube
videos, read books,
go to Sage Summit if it's in your city,
continue to try to invest
and learn and model success
because surrounding yourself
with people who've done
great things, even if it's
not, maybe there's nobody
in your family who's done great
things but by reading books
you get a window into somebody else's mind
or watching the videos that
we make, you get a window
into somebody's mind and
by constantly exposing
yourself to those things,
your perspective will shift,
your opportunities will open
up and you'll see new ways
to navigate to help you
build that business.
And so, Steven's very, like,
tactical, great strategies
and I would just add
just continue to educate,
continue to learn, continue to reach out.
Come back, ask more questions, right?
It's an amazing world we live in right now
with the opportunity to
reach so many people.
And I think people are
also willing to help
and help out young entrepreneurs.
I just like, I love, when
I see someone say they're
15 years old, it's like, I love it.
We've had 13 year olds on, it's great.
Like, I think a lot of
people want to give back
and help the next generation as well.
So, use that, it's an advantage right now,
and then go take action on it.
- Yeah, I think, don't
underestimate how much
people like me, you know,
Evan's obviously loads,
way younger than I am, but he's been down
on the mentoring floor
and I remember last year
I was on the mentoring floor
and I had a 13 year old
come along to talk to me about
a brilliant app idea that,
in this case, he'd had and he started off
and if it was going to be successful,
he was even kind of
thinking about reducing
his education and college and
that she's starting a business
in parallel with that.
So, I just can't believe how
much people like Evan, me,
would love to help younger
generation entrepreneurs.
The other thing, when I kind of grew up,
I used to kind of think,
wow, I'll go to a conference
and I'll see someone I
really respect and admire.
I sort of try and hang around
by the stage door to just,
you know, doorstep them and say, I just,
I've got this idea what
do you think of it?
And again, in your head, you will think,
oh, they won't see me, they
won't have time for me,
they'll have bodyguards,
they'll have security, you know,
and now with social media
loads of people DM me.
I'm sure it's exactly the same for Evan,
loads of people contact
him through social media.
And, you know, now Evan's
got to a business where
it's hugely successful, he
has sort of people helping him
kind of categorize that
but he still answers
a lot of that himself.
And just don't underestimate that people
are here to help you.
So if there's voices telling
you in your head that I can't
access that guy or that lady, so again,
back to what is your idea,
what are you passionate about?
Then think of the top three
people who are the experts,
the sort of, you know,
the rock stars, the gurus,
and try to reach them
through social media.
And say, look, I'm trying
to think about this.
I guarantee, if you're 15 years old,
they'll give you the time,
they'll give you the
benefit of their advice.
And from that conversation, that idea,
and it might refine your
idea, you could have a nugget
that you can actually start a business.
- Yeah.
Just to add on to that,
I would say if they are
doing an event, just
speaking at a conference
like Sage Summit, or they're
doing a hangout like this,
be first.
A lot of times you're
afraid to go up and be first
and you want to wait for
the crowd but then it just
gets too crazy.
You know, I've done three
different chunks of mentoring time
here at Sage.
My first one was right after
the keynote and it was empty
because everybody was going
to the bathroom and, you know,
chatting and getting
used to the surroundings.
And then the other two were
like insane where I'm being
triple-booked and quadra-booked
and booking on my break
and talking as I'm walking
into other meetings.
And that happens, you know.
If you try to get to a speaker
after they've done their speech,
they're going to be swamped.
Get to them first.
You want to get your question answered
on a hangout like this,
like, get in there first.
Get in there sooner so it's noticed.
So if you're trying to get
on somebody's radar at that
kind of event or a live
event, just get in there.
You have your question, this
is what you came here for,
you want to be around them,
you want to get an answer
to that question.
Don't hesitate to just jump
right in and get it answered.
- So true.
It's great advice, really great advice.
And I think conferences
are brilliant, brilliant.
And if you think about it, when
Evan's done a big conference
speech or keynoted somewhere,
typically, typically,
that individual is not
rushing away immediately to go
and do another keynote.
Normally they kind of spend, you know,
we had Michael Hyatt,
keynote here yesterday.
Amazing entrepreneur.
Actually, we had Rick,
amazing comedian, a Canadian,
Rick Mercer.
And I was blown away.
He came down here and spent
an hour on the show floor
and doing selfies and pictures.
So, again, people are really generous,
people are generous with their time.
So be first and grab
them and doorstep them
and make sure, you know,
you get your idea across
because you'll probably find,
especially if you're 15 years old,
they'll be so proud of
you going up to them
and having the confidence to do that.
And they'll spend time with you.
- Nice, cool.
Alright, let's keep going.
Ask your question, guys, in the Comments.
Paula, you are together now.
Quadra! Cool.
Hi from Tokyo.
Alright.
Hi from near London.
People are checking in
from around the world.
Oh, I just skipped, we're
skipping to the bottom.
So who are our are top faves?
Who are your top favorite entrepreneurs?
I kind of ask you this question on our,
on our Facebook hangout.
But who's your favorite entrepreneur?
Who do you look up to?
- There's so many, you know.
- This is from Marnie, by the way, Marnie.
- Hey, Marnie.
So, there are so many.
What I would say in the
spirit of there's no one who's
the perfect entrepreneur.
There's lots of people.
I love entrepreneurs who are very humble,
who have that sense of
humility to talk about
their mistakes, I think
that's self-deprivation,
it's very powerful.
And therefore, folks, you know, actually,
take people like Evan,
unbelievable, just very honest,
very, very humble guy.
But then the famous ones
include people like, you know,
Richard Branson from the sort of multi-,
sort of consumer brand experience
from airlines to music.
The guys, and we had actually
Richard on the stage last year
at Sage Summit, and
again, what a humble guy.
Unbelievable, actually, awe-inspiring.
And he's, you know, multi-millionaire
but you'd sit across
and have a cup of coffee with him
and he's just a regular guy.
And then people like, in
our industry, technology,
people like Steve Jobs.
You could argue, probably,
Steve Jobs wasn't the nicest guy
in the world but wow, what
a genius, technology genius.
And he definitely saw where
the puck was going to go
and he invented whole
different user experience
for consumers and he had
dreams about integration
and convergence of different
technologies to give consumers
something that he thought
would be very practical.
And I just, yeah, I'm sure
you've seen the movie,
or read the books.
And when you look at him
going into that board meeting
trying to persuade people about the iPhone
and half the board kind of
weren't there or maybe even
thought he was crazy.
But he had conviction,
belief, and you know,
because of that moment, it
sort of changed the world
and great companies were
mentioned like Blackberry.
They're really kind of not the powerhouse
that they were anymore.
And what is it, I think
in three years time,
it seems like the data
says they'll be six billion
smartphones on the planet.
And that is 15 years ago technology
that wasn't even invented.
So it's those guys, Jobs,
a great inspiration.
But I think there's a
lot of entrepreneurs.
You can get little nuggets
from many different entrepreneurs.
Who are your favorites?
- I agree, so I agree 100%.
My goal is never to be the next Steve Jobs
or the next anybody and
it's not the advice.
It's you want to be the
best version of yourself.
And you can pull from
lots of different people.
You like this thing about
Steve Jobs and hate all these
other things, great, like,
forget those and just
take that one thing.
And so it's what I try to
do on this channel is pull
all of these different
famous entrepreneurs
and successful people.
And if you learn one thing
from them and that makes you
a better you, that's the whole point.
If I had to pick, though, my
favorite famous entrepreneur
I default to AP Giannini,
who started Bank of America,
and he was the guy who
bet on the little guy.
He was the one who insisted
on giving loans to immigrant
workers when nobody wanted
to give loans to immigrants,
blue-collar workers.
He would lend money to
people based off a handshake
and a look in their eye,
if you can believe that from a banker.
He gave money to Walt Disney
when everybody thought he was
crazy for wanting to make a
full-length cartoon movie.
So, not a lot of people know his story,
even inside Bank of America,
you say AP Giannini,
and it's like, who's that?
He's your founder, he's
your founder, guys!
You got to know this story!
So he's, if I had to
pick one guy, it's him
because he's the believe
banker and always cared
for the little guy.
But I agree, like, you pull
from so many different people,
different things.
I pull from my parents,
I pull from successful entrepreneurs,
athletes, musicians, inventors, CEOs.
You can learn something
from anybody who's had
more success than you.
- Yeah.
Actually just one other
guy that's blown me away
and I think been a massive
influence on technology
in the last decade and
started a company in 2000.
It's a guy called Marc
Benioff and definitely worth
reading his books as well.
Inspirational leader,
great technology visionary,
but the reason why I'd
pick him out is something
we've been talking about
earlier on a broadcast.
And we featured it a
lot here at Sage Summit
is around this whole area
of compassionate capitalism.
Obviously, you want to
build a great company,
have awesome customers,
awesome technology,
all those things but we
also want to give back
to the communities and
play and active role
really kind of supporting youth and things
we really care about.
And Marc Benioff sort of pioneered that,
whatever you call it, social philanthropy.
I think the culture that
he's built in that company
is just like, just to be so admired.
So it's about building a
great business but doing it
the right way and also giving
back to the communities
and really being an active
participant of the communities.
And at the time, what I
love about Marc is back in,
what almost 20 years ago
when he started that company,
it would have been very
unpopular to do what he had
a vision and a set of values around.
Because, you know, traditionally
you launch a public company
and everybody says it's all
about return for shareholders.
And he said, actually,
I'm going to say yeah,
it is about return for
shareholders but I've also got to
support other stakeholders,
I've got to look after my colleagues,
the people who work for Salesforce,
I've got to look after my customers,
I'm fanatical about
customers and partners,
but also I've got to
play a really active role
in the communities.
And if that, in the short-term,
means that, you know,
we don't maximize profit from day one,
then that's the right thing
to do for the business
because we're about
building a sustainable,
successful business
that has huge longevity
and creates a massive legacy.
So, that is, I love the
concept and the reason why I'm
telling you about Marc is it
was completely against the,
you know, the torrent of, I guess,
the water flowing against
it and he was very contrary
in terms of that was a massive moment.
And I think has been influential
on the technology industry
and other industries where
they've come up with a big pledge
around making sure they
set up a foundation
or work in the community.
And that, you know, gives real context,
particularly for Salesforce
and companies like us,
for attracting millennials.
They feel that's a really
critical part of why they want to
work and give some loyalty to a company.
So, you know, hat tip to Marc.
And I think it really
is the way all companies
should be run.
- I'm just trying to
think if we did a video,
a top 10 on him, we may
have on the channel, maybe.
If not, we should.
- He's a, he's a such a dude.
You know, again, if he was here, you know,
he'd just sit across and
have a cup of tea or a beer
or whatever and he's just
the most regular guy,
fantastic guy.
Obviously, a multi-billionaire,
but such an amazing,
inspirational leader and shows
a great sense of humility.
- I think Darrel's about to take off.
Darrell!
Get in here!
- Hey, get in, hey, yeah.
- Darrel, Darrel.
- I like this, I like this.
Darrel, yeah.
- So, Darrel, Darrel works on team Sage.
He is the guy that does all
the behind the scenes stuff.
The computer we're using,
background you see, the chairs
and table, internet connection.
The reason why it does
so smoothly is this guy.
Here he comes.
- What Darrel does for me,
I'm a pretty average guy,
and Darrel, through social
media, makes me look okay.
So . . .
- No, it's a lie, it's a lie.
It's all you, it's all Steven.
- No, it's all Darrel.
You know, he just puts me
forward but he's the guy
that makes it all happen.
The wind beneath our wings.
- Wind beneath your wings.
- I love it.
- Darrel's got to catch
his flight back to London
so we won't keep him but thank you, man.
- Any message, any message to our viewers?
Come on, Darrel, you got
to do a little nugget.
Darrel makes this happen and supports us.
- Word of advice.
Here it is.
Put on the spot.
- Sage words.
- Sage word is use channel you
can to get yourself out there
to the most relevant audience to you.
So, if that's Instagram, that's great.
If it's Twitter, that's great.
Work out what's the right
channel for you and just use it
to the best you can with good
quality content like this.
- Awesome.
- I love it, man.
- Love it.
- Have a good flight.
- Safe, safe flight, buddy.
- Alright, cool.
We got a little spontaneity
happening there.
- I love it, good job.
- Okay, guys, there were so
many questions that came in
that YouTube reset the thing.
It went all the way to the
bottom so you had a question
we didn't get to, ask it again
because too much is happening.
It's a good problem to have.
Roy.
Can you touch on whether
the process is different
if my focus is a cause
rather than entrepreneurship
like targeting special needs parents?
So, we're talking about
taking an idea into reality.
If it's for a cause
instead of for a business,
is the process any different?
- I think the process is
the same and I think, wow,
you know, I think both Evan
and I would applaud your cause
around special needs.
And again, I think it's,
what is, identifying the gap
that's there now and identifying
how through your idea
you can actually improve
the wellbeing of parents
of special needs kids, in this case.
And, you know, I think
there's many gaps I think
whether you're in the US or
Canada or any developed economy.
There's a lot of gaps
opening up because, you know,
the traditional sort of
welfare system is struggling
to keep up with both the
demographic shift in terms
of things, and also other
stuff like mental health,
all these things that we're really able
to talk about it now.
Whereas probably a decade ago
people just kind of hid
this stuff in the cupboards.
So there's a lot of
stuff and a lot of people
who are in need in a lot of support,
so if you've got an
idea around that, again,
it's making that idea come to reality.
And I think around that
one, it sounds like,
without knowing the
details, but it sounds like
you can have an idea
where at very low cost,
you could actually create
something that you could
test drive with a selection of parents,
just to validate your idea.
And then again, scale
it up, and I think that
would be a fantastic course.
- I was trying to scroll
back to the question
but there's so many that
came in that I lost it so.
Roy, it's a good problem.
Same advice that I
started off with, I think,
like consistent action.
Like, whatever that idea you
have is to reach special needs
parents, whatever thing
you want to create,
if it's not a company,
if it's just an initiative
or project, partnerships,
whatever it is, that you
do something everyday,
you don't let your head
talk you out of doing
the big thing that you have in mind,
and that you create an
environment that allows you
to wake up everyday, whether
it's going for a 6:00 AM run
like Steven does everyday,
or watching a video,
or reading a book, or reminding
yourself of the vision.
Like, whatever it is that
gets you into the mode that
everyday you're going to
go off and take action
on achieving your vision,
because otherwise it just
stays here and never comes out.
So whether you're building
a business or just moving
a cause forward, I believe
it's the same thing.
- Yeah, I think so.
And I think in that case you're probably,
you want to prototype
something, test drive it.
Then also, I think as an entrepreneur,
what you've got to think about
is how do you scale that?
Actually, I think Darrel's
comment is, again,
through social media, through content,
that's a great way to scale a business.
So, but it's always fantastic
to validate it first
and go and test drive it, road
test it with, in this case,
parents with special needs kids.
- Roy's writing back, thank
you in caps, so much gentlemen.
Three exclamation points.
- Oh, thanks, Roy.
- Feeling the love there.
Okay, let's go to this one here.
Grandpa's farm goes sailing.
That's a creative name.
How critical is a
multi-platform marketing plane
as opposed to just
concentrating on YouTube?
- Oh, thanks.
- We got to get Darrel back in here.
- Darrel's the man on this.
I think, yeah, what do you
call it, multi-platform,
multi-channel, I think the key thing is
where is your audience?
And if you're audi-, you
know, I was down in Madrid
last week talking about Iberia,
which is Spain and Portugal.
No one uses Twitter down
in Portugal so they use
a totally different,
obviously, and Chinese,
totally different stuff.
So every audience, every
country has unique elements
around what the social channel is.
So, I personally think YouTube's amazing.
Again, we had Chad Hurley,
who's the founder of YouTube,
up on the stage.
- Last year.
Wow, last year, and what an inspiration.
But what he said was, I think at the time,
he was hoping that would
have maybe 10,000 videos
kind of loaded in something
like a month or something crazy.
And now I think it's like
there's is it 400 hours
of content loaded every minute?
- Oh, it's, I don't even know, it's crazy.
- And what, there's two billion users
or something crazy like that.
So, he could never have
estimated just how YouTube's
become all pervasive.
And again, what an
amazing kind of channel,
I think it's incredible for content.
Video, video content is really rich
and normally it's fantastic.
Now, you might go to
some parts of the world,
if you're not living in the US or Canada,
and you might have really
kind of slow bandwidth.
So that's got an impact on video
and all these sort of things.
So, just again, think
about what Darrel said,
what's the channel that really
your audiences are tuned to
and then put a lot of the
wood behind that arrow.
- That's good, I like that from last time.
- The wood behind the arrow, yeah, yeah.
- It's exactly right, you know.
It's marketing 101.
You want to be where your
customers are, you know.
If you're selling to red-headed
women and this is conference
of red-headed women, like,
you want to be there.
You know, wherever your audience
is, you need to be there.
The only thing I would
add is combine it with
what you're good at.
You know, if you suck at
doing videos and the idea
of doing videos just terrifies you,
and you're a great writer, you
don't have to be on YouTube,
right, you can go to Medium,
you can go to LinkedIn,
you can go to Facebook, you
can start a blog, right?
You can go to Twitter, there's
a lot of other options.
You're customers are in
a lot of different places
so you don't have to
do all of those things,
just figure out where your audience is,
combine it with what you're good at.
You know, Steven started
his new vlog series,
it can do well.
Most CEOs, I've met a lot
of them, are super boring
and would not have a great personal vlog.
And so maybe that's not the
best path for them, right?
Even though the audience is on YouTube,
so you've got to combine
those two things together.
I think entrepreneurs try to do everything
and then you do nothing well.
You try to do YouTube
and Twitter and LinkedIn
and Medium and Facebook and
Instagram and everything
and then everything sucks.
So, pick the platform
that has your audience
and combines your natural talent
and then make that awesome!
So that if I watch your YouTube
video or I see your Tweet,
I'm going to want to consume
it again and share it
with my friends.
Making content that you're
proud of it way more important
than making decent
content across everything.
- Yeah, actually, that's
such an important, Evan,
and any advice you'd give in
terms of the different choices
between the social channels?
You know, because there's a
lot of factors in terms of
whether it's content, whether
it's a really high quality
photograph pic, you know, there's
a lot of different things.
Any advice you'd give?
- Well, if you look at like
Twitter, YouTube, Facebook,
they have all audiences.
They're so big that they cover everything.
Instagram, too.
You can go niche.
Like, LinkedIn is going to be
more for the business crowd
and, you know, Pinterest
hits a certain crowd,
and SnapChat skews younger
but it's coming up older.
So, you can be a little
strategic about that.
But, yeah, leverage your strengths.
If you're a great photographer, you know,
you take beautiful pictures,
you can turn that into a YouTube video.
But it's still pictures,
it's not as great as if you
turn it into Instagram
photos or Facebook photos.
Or partner up with a motivational speaker
and use their quotes to be on
top of your pictures, right?
So, leverage the thing
that you're really good at
with where you're audience
is and just start with one.
- Yeah.
- I would get all the
domains of all of them.
Like, get the handles.
So, if a new thing opened up,
I would get the Evan Carmichael
love, you know, SuTube,
just to have it and then
I'd figure out later
if I'm actually going to use it or not
so nobody takes your name.
- Yeah, actually, in some
respects, what Evan said
has huge impact on me,
said start with one.
I'd also, I'd encourage
you to start with one idea.
Don't try and do too many things
because you kind of become
all things to all people
and you're good at nothing.
So it's the same with social media.
Pick one channel.
Same with kind of product or service,
just pick one to start with.
And then, you know, we call it
a sort of beachhead strategy.
You own one beachhead,
you do really well there,
then you think about the
next one that's related
and then you do the next
one and multi next one.
And that's how you kind of ultimately
scale a great business.
- I love it.
He's writing back to say
once again thanks for
the awesome content and motivation.
So that's great.
Glad we can help.
Next, Zack.
Does a positive outlook
play a part in quelling
some young aspiring
entrepreneur's anxiety.
So role of positive outlook
on quelling anxiety for entrepreneurs.
- Yeah, I think that's so good.
We better start with the
man who invented #belief.
This is him on my left.
It's Evan.
So important.
- Yeah, I mean, just like I
started off the talk saying
I think the mindset is super
important, I think, you know,
10% of your life is what happens to you
and 90% is how you react to it
and how you choose to look at it.
You know, is this, it's the
difference between is this,
am I having a bad day or
am I having a growth day?
Right?
This is a me growing day.
There's a concept of would you
know the difference between
being buried and being planted?
Because when you're underground
all you see is darkness
around you and maybe you're
just being planted to grow
stronger to come up and create
this amazing thing versus
I'm buried, I'm suffocated,
I can't do anything.
If you look at all the people
who've had massive success,
it's not inherited wealth,
but genuine massive success
that they created on their own,
it doesn't come from people
who had super wealthy parents, right?
People who grew up with massive
safety nets and trust funds.
It's the people who had nothing growing up
and they turned it into something amazing.
And I think a big challenge
is if you don't have anything
right now, the people around
you can be telling you
that you don't have anything,
that you won't amount to anything,
that you don't have the
education or background or money
or anything and so
changing your environment,
whether it's watching videos
like this or reading books,
all the stuff I talked about,
whatever it is that gets you excited,
because we've all had
these moments of boldness
and excitement and velocity,
one of Steven's favorite words,
we've all had these moments
where we want to just go out
and charge and do these amazing things.
Like, what led to that?
And then how do you make that
part of your daily routine
instead of happening to come
across it at five o'clock
on a Tuesday afternoon,
so that you're applying it
on a regular basis.
I think the mindset, the
environment is super,
super important, much more than
whatever resources you have.
- Yeah, I think it's probably
one of the most important
aspects of a successful entrepreneur.
And the thing we celebrate is
we've all got different personalities.
You know, we're probably,
ironically, introverts.
And yet, you know, sometimes
that has sort of naturally
made us quite anxious about stuff.
But, what I would say is there's
just such strong evidence
that positivity and optimism
is actually not only inspiring
but it's also quite
contagious, it's infectious.
So, and you're customers will detect this.
And it's tough to fake.
So authenticity, we've talked
so much about authenticity,
it's such a powerful, compelling quality.
But if you're going to hire
like someone to come and work
with you, you've got to be
positive about your dream
and your vision, your idea.
So, and there's just
starting to be a load of like
sort of behavioral psychology
written around this
and sort of nudging behaviors.
But I think you waking up
everyday and having conviction,
having belief, and
expressing that in optimism
and positivity about how your product's
going to change the world
in its own little way,
is very compelling.
And I think the other
thing, just practically,
because you can't be always
sort of on and always positive,
so sometimes we all
kind of have a bad day,
whenever that is.
And if that's the case,
maybe, I don't know,
you don't want to do
sort of front line work,
you want to do stuff about thinking.
So, if you're not having a great day,
do some thoughtful work, do
some stuff about, I don't know,
product development, whatever.
But if you're having, you're in the zone,
you're having a good day, you're positive,
get out there, talk to
customers, talk to media,
post stuff on social media.
So play to your strengths
in terms of how you are
because none of us have like
a consistent sort of mood
that just always operates
at the same level.
But I would, I would
absolutely always be encouraged
by all the entrepreneurs I've met with.
When they're in the zone,
they're unbelievably positive.
Because what they're doing
is really persuading us all
there's a better way,
there's a better world,
there's a better product,
there's a different way to do stuff,
there's a different way to crack the code.
And all of us get compelled
to follow in that vision
then it creates a movement.
And that's how you scale great companies.
- I like it.
Vali's asking how do
you transform a bad day
into a bad minute or hour?
- Actually, a great way, so if you are,
you're not in the zone, whatever.
You could be depressed, you
could just, just had it,
something happens which
kind knocks you off track.
What you want to do is choo,
actually sort of cauterize that
and just move on.
It could be loads of
different things, you could,
and it depends on what works for you.
You could go for a walk, go for a run.
I tend to, you know,
if I'm, I'm certainly,
the way that I beat jet
lag and stuff like that
is just go running, gets me feeling good,
gets the old endorphins
going, all that sort of stuff.
Or you could just go and go to a mentor,
you could go and have
a coffee with someone,
you could do breathing exercises,
you could do mindfulness,
you could do whatever
works for you, really.
I think it's really
important that you are always
your unique personality and you
find just what works for you
and allows you to kind of
recalibrate your optimism
and positivity and come back.
And if you can't, you know, its great,
instead of having a bad
day, just have a bad minute.
Wow, that's powerful, really is powerful.
And then bounce back.
- A couple of things that help me.
One, try to solve the problem.
Like, if it's a problem that's happening,
there's this crisis in my business,
or there's something I need to solve,
okay, go out and solve the problem.
Like, do it even if it's scary
because the more you just
let it sit, the problem's
not just going to go away
on its own.
So go out and solve it.
If it's the kind of
thing that I can't solve
or I'm frustrated for a different reason,
I like the line of
turning your expectations
into appreciation.
So, I'm sitting in traffic, you know,
or I'm waiting for the
elevator and it's not working
or something happens that's
just beyond my control,
just turning your expectations
into appreciation,
gratitude, like, I'm in a
car, like, this is great.
I can drive and like imagine
if it was 100 years ago,
I'd be on a horse, you know.
And I get to talk to people
like you guys over the internet
everyday and it wouldn't
have been able to happen
100 years ago, right?
Just that kind of stuff just
resets and makes me realize
that most of these things
that I'm upset about
don't actually really matter
and to get back on the horse
and go do the thing that I care about.
So solve the problem if there is a problem
you can solve immediately, don't delay.
And two, trade your
expectations for appreciation.
- Yeah, actually, the other
thing, just looking back
on my career, you know, you
do worry about stuff at times.
But when I look back on it
with the benefit of hindsight,
there's never been anything
that we didn't overcome.
And I think there's a great
quality around perseverance.
And you just got to give yourself context.
You've got to step back from the moment,
sort of be your own shadow,
and then watch yourself
in the moment.
And sometimes when you
do that you think, wow,
I'm being pretty ridiculous,
I'm getting worried about stuff
I don't need to worry about.
And there's kind of a few
rules for entrepreneurs,
rules of life, really.
You should only worry
about what you can change.
No point worrying about
stuff you can't, you know,
if you're worried about, I
don't know, the US president,
you're worried about
stuff, what can you do?
Honestly, what can you do about it?
Let's worry about stuff we
can change, your customers,
the product, the service,
the channels, you know,
those things you can really spend time on.
And just become very pragmatic.
But what I would say as well, you know,
starting a business takes
the guts, the perseverance,
just to go cross the line
and take the first step.
But then a lot of it really is
about continued perseverance,
tenacity, grit, and all those
sort of qualities come out
to the fore in terms of just
the consistency of execution
over the longterm to be
proud of what you created.
So, I think a lot of it
is definitely, you know,
in your hands and we would
definitely encourage you
in that vein to be really
positive, really optimistic.
And when you are having a
bad day just allow yourself
to step back, just be
objective, and say, you know,
back to Evan's point, what is the problem
we're trying to solve
here and how do we fix it?
And then you're creative,
you're smart guys,
you'll find a way.
- I like it.
Daniel's writing in.
How do you balance real
life, kids, bill paying,
with investing in your ideas when you have
more month than money?
Not sure what that last part
is but basically the idea
of being able to balance
your life, kids, bill paying,
with trying to start a business.
- I think that's a tough one.
And I would say, you know,
probably this a where I question
some of the sort of media
portrayal of entrepreneurs
and sometimes entrepreneurs
are painted as people
who have everything and never
have to make compromises.
I don't know those entrepreneurs
because I, you know,
for Evan, maybe talk, Evan's got kids,
there's a lot of juggling you have to do.
We sort of have a belief,
I absolutely love life,
I love being an entrepreneur
and I say in Sage
to my colleagues, you
know, think of us as like
the most excited start-up in the world.
But in a business, I think
you do have big dreams.
Across your life, the sadness,
the only sadness about life
is you just get one, one life.
And I kind of think for people like Evan,
one life is never enough
because we've just got so much
to do with our one life.
But what does that mean?
What it means to me is that
in terms of the context
of balancing things, I think, you know,
the reality is you've got one
shot, you've got one life,
you've probably got
loads of business ideas
and you have to juggle,
you have to make compromise
if you're having kids, you
have to, what I would advise,
honestly, I think it's
tough to have it all.
And, you know, have a
career and work crazy hours
and balance your life and
keep all the balls juggling
in the air, it's tough because
you have to compromise.
But what I would say, and this
would be advice that I would
give to my younger self,
just go into every situation
with your eyes wide open.
Always have the discussion,
whether it's with kids
or partners or whoever it is,
to be as honest as you can
at that point in time.
What you tend to find, again
this sort of with the benefit
of hindsight, is you can never
really predict the future.
The downside of me being
an optimist, in some ways,
as an entrepreneur is
sometimes I say, well,
we're going to have to double-down
for the next, I don't know,
say 30 days, 90 days.
My experience tells me
those 30 days always become
90 days or 180 days.
It's always taken me longer
than I've anticipated.
So my sort of, I guess,
answer to you question is,
I think you do have to compromise,
you have to juggle the balls.
But I think with that comes
a responsibility to be honest
to yourself and honest with
the people you care about.
And try and just be, you know,
just have that conversation
so you go in with your eyes wide open.
But also, just to
acknowledge that actually
things might change over time.
If your business really picks
up and it's going gangbusters
it might take more time.
And therefore you're going to
have to double down a bit longer
so you kind of need a
reset and a checkpoint
down that journey.
And again, worth having
the honest conversation
and just making sure all
the people you care about
are on board and all committed
and have that kind of shared meaning.
- Yeah, I'm reminded of Steve Wozniak,
whose advice for entrepreneurs,
he co-founded Apple with Steve
Jobs, would say don't focus
on what you don't have,
rather, focus on what can do
with what you do have.
And I think even just that mindset shift
is a huge difference because
we tend to focus on all
the things we don't have,
the money we don't have,
the time we don't have, the
resources we don't have,
the connections we don't have,
the education we don't have,
and if that's the world you live in,
you're never going to build anything.
You can't just focus on
what you don't have because
you're operating in a world of scarcity.
Where if you focus on, listen,
I have half an hour a night,
that's what I have.
Great, like, use that half an
hour to build your business,
every single day.
You don't need to have fancy
gear or tools or anything
to get started.
You just start with what you
have, where you are, you start.
You want to start a YouTube
channel, get out your phone
and start making videos.
Do you want to make huge productions?
Yes, great.
That's your longterm goal.
So start working on it because
nobody's going to fund that
for you, you have to bet on
yourself and start putting in
the work to get good at it,
using the tools that you have.
And so even just thinking about it,
like one of the most important
skills of an entrepreneur
is resourcefulness because you
never have enough resources
to do what you want to do.
So we have to be creative,
we have to be resourceful,
that's how new things are invented.
You can't just throw
money at a problem, right,
you need resourcefulness.
And so it's a great thing
for you to learn right now.
And it's a real situation, right?
You have bills, you have a family,
you've got mouths to feed,
you don't have a ton of time.
Great.
Everybody's fighting their own battle.
There's a lot of things that
I could say about my life
or the reasons why I
can't build my business,
just like everybody else.
But I focus, I make time for it.
At the start it was an hour
a day, half an hour a day,
whatever it was, and you
start expanding as you start
being able to provide
value and earn an income.
And so just that mindset shift
of I'm not going to focus on
what I don't have, here's what I do have,
here's what I'm grateful for,
here's how I'm going to maximize
what I do have right now.
And how can I be more
resourceful to figure things out?
Just switching that mindset
will make a huge, huge,
huge difference, much more
than any specific tactic
that I can give you.
- Yeah, that's a great quote.
Resourcefulness is always
the answer, not resources.
And if you thinking of
starting your business,
actually, it's a great
thing to do to moonlight.
So, you know, you time
slice to what Evan said
so you're working full-time,
you're funding, you know,
the family, the mortgage,
the kids, and all that stuff.
But maybe, when you put the
kids to bed, you actually
sit down and think
about your business idea
and use the evenings
to start your business
and start your big idea and
how you're going to do that.
Maybe carve some time out
on the weekends to do that.
And then you start your
business and when it's kind of
going up and it's really taking off,
then you think about when do you step down
from your full-time employment.
But I know, again, loads
of great entrepreneurs
who have, effectively,
moonlighted to kind of pump start
their business and it's
been very effective.
And the amazing thing
about entrepreneurs is just
the resourcefulness
that people come up with
in terms of the scarcest
resource we all have is time.
Making it go as far as
it can to be successful.
- One thing I always remind
myself of is no matter
how bad a situation is,
remember somebody has it worse.
Somebody's had it worse than you,
had fewer resources than you
and went on to do amazing,
amazing things.
You know, if you think
of Oprah growing up,
you know, being raped by family
members and being so poor
that she had to wear potato
sacks to school as a dress.
And just, it's story after
story after story after story
of these ultra-successful
people who started with way less
than what you already have
right now and the difference is
they didn't focus on what
they don't have, right?
Focus on what you do
have and be resourceful.
- Yeah, actually, when I was
out in the Silicon Valley
at the time, sort of late
'90s, loads of companies
raising money and VC money.
Typically the companies
that raised loads of money,
not always successful.
And also it destroyed
their culture because,
to what Evan said, and I
think this is so fundamental,
is that I wouldn't necessary
argue that you want to
run a company on fumes,
but you want to run it
lean and mean.
Think that start-up, keep
that start-up mentality
as you grow and scale.
And there's some great papers
around founders' mentality,
which keeps you fresh, keeps
you young, keeps you focused
on customer obsession.
And there's so many companies
I see who grow and grow
and then they become wasteful
and they kind of lose that
kind of wake up call of why
they started their adventure
in the first place.
So, again, you know, as
a start-up entrepreneur,
I really think it's pretty
important if you really sort of
almost run on fumes and you
haven't got loads of money
to spend on marketing and stuff like that,
you'll find ways through just
creativity and resourcefulness
to get the job done, to meet
the end results, and to find
some really efficient ways to do that.
- I love it.
I know we're starting
to run short on time.
Steven's got a crazy schedule
here today at Sage Summit.
One last question.
Let's get to Cherique
who's saying does setting
unrealistic goals work?
- I'm realistic.
I guess, if I reframe
that and said, you know,
whether you call it big, hairy, audacious,
I certainly think, well,
there's a couple of things.
Goals are a result of plans, okay?
One thing that's really
important and we probably should
talk about this sometime, if
you do an incremental plan
from where you are, you
can only see the next step.
What you want to do as an entrepreneur
is say the end game of, you know,
what is it I want to dream?
And you almost live in the future
and then come back to the present.
So, and this is the way most
successful companies actually plan.
They'll say, you know, three years,
what do we wan to do?
You know, we want to, say for Sage,
launched a million
businesses, new businesses,
help them get up and running.
So if we did that then in three years,
what would we have to do
in year and then kind of
work it back to month one.
And then I think it really
does give you an opportunity
to have very ambitious plans.
I think it's great to have ambitious plans
and share those plans.
And the more ambition you have, typically,
the more successful you are.
The other thing I'd say is just the way
the human psyche works.
If you say, I'll have a plan
where we'll have, I don't know,
half a million dollars
of revenue in five years,
or something like that.
If you said, because the way it works is,
then you'd be happy if
you maybe got $400,000,
but if you said actually we
want to do a million dollars,
it just drives your mentality
to be more ambitious
and achieve more.
So I would set yourself higher
goals and higher ambitions
because, effectively, you'll
get probably 90% of that.
And 90% of a double in
ambition level is much better
than 100% of a very low ambition.
- Yeah I think it's super
important to have a big goal
that you're shooting towards,
to have a reason to get up everyday.
You know, I want to help
a billion entrepreneurs,
that's inspiring, it leads me
to create a YouTube channel
and do book deals and speak and do things
that has the potential
to hit a lot of people
At the same time, I think you
also need to enjoy the work.
I'm not only doing this to hit this goal,
whatever your big crazy
goal is, but I like grinding
every single day.
Like, I like do this, I
like editing my videos,
I like talking to you one-on-one.
So, I think too many people
just have a goal and it's like,
okay, I'll do whatever it
takes just to hit that goal.
I don't think that's the right mindset.
I think you have to
actually enjoy the work
that you're doing every
single day as well.
You're enjoying the climb
almost more than hitting the top
of the mountain, right?
Because you hit the top and you're like,
well, now what do I do?
You got to climb some more, right?
So, goals are great, I love it,
it's part of what inspires me daily.
But I think even more
important is actually enjoying
the day-to-day work that you're doing.
- Yeah, I got a metaphor,
because we're in Toronto.
So, you're going to love this,
I hope you love this anyway.
So, I'd say as an entrepreneur
you want to shoot for the stars.
But you might find by
shooting for the stars,
you land on top of the CN Tower.
That's a pretty good place to land.
- I like it, I like it.
Cool.
Well, thank you guys so much for watching.
Steven, I know you've got
to run to your next thing.
How do you want to end this out?
Do we have a quote to end
it off, a final thought,
what do you, how do you
want to finish this session?
- Yeah, just, we had a
great speaker down with us
on Sage Summit, Michael
Hyatt, who's an amazing tech
visionary, Canadian, very inspiring.
And the quote that he left me with is
I'm a 20-year overnight success.
So, you know, you've got
dreams, you've got ambitions,
you had great questions here.
But, actually, you need
perseverance and you need tenacity.
And the first think you've
got to do in the context
of today's kind of broadcast
is take that first step.
And we compel you to take
that first step forward
because then you start living your dreams
and you get momentum behind you
and you get confidence when you
start believing in yourself.
And the more you belief in yourself,
just the more successful you'll be.
- I love it.
Well, thank you guys for watching.
We're going to do it again next month.
Let us know in the Comments
down below what topics
you want us to cover
and not in the live chat
because YouTube destroys that,
in the Comments afterwards, below.
Steven, thank you again, man.
- Great job, awe, great, Evan.
Really enjoyed it, great
event in your city.
Thanks for being an amazing
host and go Blue Jays.
- Thanks for the love, guys.
Believe.
Well see you soon.
And let's end it.